mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir le conseil des ministres a
adopté ce matin le projet de loi sur
l'interruption de la grossesse tel qu'il
avait été préparé par le ministre de la
santé monsieur giscard d'estaing a
estimé que ce projet répondait avec
humanité et lucidité aux problèmes posés
ce sont naturellement les parlementaires
qui auront le dernier mot
le projet sera examiné par l'assemblée
nationale le 26 novembre
le problème c'est de remplacer la
législation de 1920 et 1923 sur
l'avortement qui n'est plus du tout
appliqué aujourd'hui déjà le
gouvernement de monsieur messmer avait
proposé un projet de loi l'année
dernière pour modifier cette législation
c'était une libéralisation importante
l'interruption de la grossesse aurait
été permise quand elle présentait un
danger immédiat ou lointains pour la
santé physique psychique ou mentale de
la mère en cas de risque de
malformations du foetus et lorsque la
grossesse était la conséquence d'un acte
de violence ou criminelle après un débat
mouvementé de deux jours à l'assemblée
nationale le projet de monsieur
poniatowski à leur ministre de la santé
était repoussé le 14 décembre dernier
par 255 voix contre 212 le nouveau
projet présenté par madame veil est
adoptée aujourd'hui par le conseil des
ministres est beaucoup plus libéral
s'il est adopté avant la dixième semaine
de la grossesse l'interruption seraient
autorisés mais elles seraient soumises à
des précautions pour protéger la femme
l'intervention devrait obligatoirement
être faite par un médecin et en milieu
hospitalier c'est-à-dire soit dans un
hôpital soit dans une clinique
elles ne seraient pas remboursés par la
sécurité sociale après la 10e semaine
l'interruption de la grossesse ne seront
autorisés que dans des cas exceptionnels
c'est-à-dire lorsque cette grossesse
présente un péril grave pour la santé de
la mère et des risques élevé
d'affections graves pour l'enfant il
s'agit alors d'un avortement
thérapeutique qui exige la vie de deux
médecins dont un agréé par la cour
d'appel
je pense que la situation actuellement
est une situation injuste est mauvaise
elle est injuste pour les femmes parce
qu'en définitive c'est surtout
entre les plus démunis les plus
défavorisés que la loi pénale
actuellement et rigoureuse pour les
autres il est très facile d'aller
rowland est très facile d'aller on en
mettait et même quelquefois aussi facile
de trouver un médecin qui fasse en
france il y en a nous le savons mais en
revanche pour les femmes qui sont perdus
les moins informés qu'ils n'ont pas
d'argent qui sont perdus soit dans leur
campagne soit même dans des conditions
de vie très difficiles dans les îles
elles ne savent pas comment faire quand
elle s'attend d'un enfant qu'elles ne
peuvent vraiment pas assumer alors c'est
pour ça que trouvons l'association
mauvaise et que nous estimons
souhaitable de la modifier parce qu'il
ya trop de femmes actuellement tiendront
une grossesse dans des conditions
pénibles ce sera pas remboursé par la
sécurité sociale
le texte ne précise rien en matière de
sécurité sociale donc on se retrouve
dans le droit commun c'est-à-dire que
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un acte médical qui a
une raison thérapeutique comme
l'avortement thérapeutique qui est
autorisé par le texte la sécurité
sociale remboursera lorsqu au contraire
il ne s'agira pas d'un acte médical
la sécurité sociale compensera pas ce
que vous ne craignez pas que ça remplace
un peu la contraception
j'espère bien que non seulement bien sûr
il faut du temps pour que la
contraception dans les murs
vous savez qu'elle n'a été autorisée que
depuis 1967 que ce n'est que la loi qui
est actuellement entre enfin le projet
de loi qui est actuellement en cours de
discussion devant le parlement qui
permet de faire une large information
est pour l'instant trop de femmes en
fait ne savent pas très bien qu'elles
peuvent aller voir un médecin qu'elles
peuvent pas obtenir une
une ordonnance de soi pour se faire
poser un stérilet soit pour acheter des
contraceptifs oraux ce qui fait qu'elles
n'ont pas encore pris l'habitude de la
contraception et c'est pour ça qu'il est
encore temps d'avortements clandestins
et c'est pour cela que législateur est
obligé d'intervenir et d'ailleurs le
projet de loi précise de façon très
rigoureuse que le cadre de l'option
grossesse la femme de vagues devra être
obligatoirement informé des méthodes
contraceptives
nous espérons en tout cas si elle a
recours à l'avortement scène sera plus
forte à plusieurs si je venais pas voter
qu'est ce qui va se passer
alors on restera dans la situation
actuelle c'est à dire une situation
d'une loi inapplicable qui n'est pas
appliqué ce problème de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse est un problème
grave puisqu'il touche à la conscience
de chacun et de chaque et c'est la
raison pour laquelle le prix de la
république à la fin du débat du conseil
des ministres a tenu ce matin à faire
une déclaration que je voudrais ici
sites tels sont les motifs qui ont
conduit le gouvernement à établir à
projets mettant fin à une situation de
désordre et d'injustice et apportant une
solution mesurer et humaines à l'un des
problèmes les plus difficiles de notre
temps je cite les problèmes ce problème
qui continuera à poser à chaque individu
la question graves et douloureuses des
responsabilités qu'ils exercent
vis-à-vis de la vie il d'autant qu'un
texte législatif qui lui permettra
jamais de ce décès ce projet de loi sera
discuté à l'assemblée nationale à partir
du 26 novembre prochain